I'll say no to appease the whites
[Music]
the internet is brought to you by Roman
watch afterwards for more details hi I'm
nimesh Patel I'm here to answer the
internet do you think there are more
porn stars or murderers in the world I
would really hope there are more porn
stars and if there are more murderers
than they're doing a terrible job they
need their own only fans for sure
58 of barcelia said there are more
murderers What a Sad group
would you rather live in colonial times
or you're 2500 well I know what they did
to my people in colonial times so
2500. I'm going back with these guns
since colonial times I promise you that
much if I went back in time to Colonial
times I doubt they had 6-1 Indian dudes
back
left and right hooks would you go to
football game at a 70 000 seat Stadium
if you knew that 500 seats would get
ejected into a black hole but everyone
who didn't get rejected would get five
million dollars I don't know what the
math of 500 out of 70 000 is good though
bro yeah those are pretty good odds no I
would not really I don't trust my
actually you know what I've always want
I've always wanted to go into a black
hole so I think I would take those
chances just to see what would happen
who knows maybe come on the other side
in colonial times get to murder some
British people
would you rather eat all your food
through a straw or have all your food
tossed into your mouth well I've had
food through a straw before and it's
annoying and I also eat all my food by
having it tossed in my mouth already as
it is so that's a short and easy answer
would you kill Baby Hitler if it had to
be in a very gruesome way I could only
imagine killing Baby Hitler in a very
gruesome way you know like a little head
twist like a Cabbage Patch doll or some
[ __ ] like that no problem man
this [ __ ] is light work would you rather
have your girl be able to see it or hear
everything you do when she's would you
rather have your girl be able to see or
hear every see or hear everything you do
when she's not around yeah I'd rather
ever hear everything because I think uh
from a visual perspective it would just
be sad to see me just do
my hands like just like no audio if
you're seeing someone do know it was
like my day is very [ __ ] mundane it's
like me just sitting around wondering
what I'm doing if you had one free throw
and if you make it you get a million
dollars but if you miss you never get to
text again would you shoot it in a
heartbeat I would shoot this [ __ ]
free throw it from the line right now
probably like 75 like I'll try to go
shoot free throws every every morning if
I can I also hate texting I think it's
the [ __ ] most annoying [ __ ] in the
world I'll give that up now if I could
but that question first time
I'm [ __ ] not no and that's it's five
minutes about six seven years now like
four or five years to find this game
people are done it's starting to turn
man yeah yeah the anti-text train is
coming yeah yeah right would you rather
relive your best sports moment or your
best sex moment not I mean yes you don't
have to any my best sports moment a
thousand percent of the time my best
sports moment I remember it very clearly
we were I used to live in a building on
40th and 10th we were playing basketball
two on two uh it was I was in the uh in
the in our building I was like in a
corner to win the game wait how old are
you this way I was like 25 26 years old
usually people got to go back to like
literally no no we were playing balls
two on two I was in corner to back can I
pass a double team I just put it up bang
game winner I was like [ __ ] you suck my
I remember it was such a it was such a
moment it was like game meant nothing
whatsoever two random neighbors
all right dude yeah it's like my dick
and I don't even know these dudes uh
infinitely yeah I didn't know what my
best sex moment is
I hope I have yet to have it would you
rather be the most attractive person in
the world but blind the best singer in
the world but deaf or the best chef in
the world but have no sense of taste oh
that's a good one I would never want to
be blind so that's easy I've had no
taste before and really that wasn't that
bad best thing I need to be able to hear
[ __ ] and I I would love to be able to a
fantastic singer but best chef in the
world and have no taste because like I
think I would be that would make me like
Beethoven right yes and I've also had no
sense of taste and you know what I'm not
really missing anything I don't really
eat that well anyway
if I could remember the [ __ ] flavors
would you rather go back to being 18 old
18 years old knowing everything you know
now or get a million dollars I would
easily go back to being 18 years old
knowing everything I know now a million
dollars I would hope to earn it within
like two days of knowing everything that
I know now what's the what's the number
of money like how high is that another
need to be for you to pick the money
100 million dollars
yeah yeah why how much would it have to
be going for 50 75 million I mean we're
just adjusting for inflation man
I would love to be 18 again and do
everything all over again I would drop
out of school immediately you know just
like start Google
no no yeah I would do that too maybe
easily get a million dollars if you had
the choice between world peace or a sum
of money what is the sum of money to not
choose World Peace
a couple billion dollars a couple
billion yeah yeah I think if I had to
choose between world peace and some sum
of money that sum of money would have
had to be a couple of billion dollars
I'm very [ __ ] utopian don't let the
you know capitalism fool you like that
gold chains put 100 million on the table
you're not taking it 500 million like
what are you saying yeah yeah I mean so
I mean we should we could play we could
play this game yeah two million dollars
165
000. Chipotle for a year yeah I don't
know I mean world peace we never had it
before but it seems like it'd be [ __ ]
amazing it would there be no need for
money if you had world peace I'm sorry
to be this [ __ ] left-wing liberal
dude
turmoil a little bit right nah man you
ever done shrooms
would you accept the million dollars to
be deported from the United States you
can never come back but you get that one
take one person with you [ __ ] no I
[ __ ] love America America is the
greatest country on the planet thank you
China to name it special
but yeah no I would I would definitely
not do that if you want to last longer
than just seven minutes in bed go to get
roll 20 off your first order it's get
roman.com answer would you take a
million dollars to be one of the picket
people for the Westboro Baptist Church
during a fallen soldiers funeral
he shouldn't have been gay
background why not Audi I already talked
[ __ ] about soldiers
it's not 100 no problem bro you think
you could throw a football further in
the 1940s Heisman winner 1940 is a
heisman's winners were also like postmen
right like they're just like a
regularized jobs I'll say no to appease
the whites sure
thank you
if you're watching on YouTube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and John what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that Bell icon